okay and the key thing I think to keep  in mind is that DNA your genome  definitely teaches you a lot about you  but we need to understand the  interaction of everything else which we  call the environment but it's basically  everything else that is non DNA and how  it interacts with DNA yeah for things to  happen right eating a lot of stress is  bad for example some a lot of stress is  bad right although some level of stress  can be good yeah right so it depends it  depends what you're measuring so then  that's called epigenetics that's great  so that's the way the environment  affects the way that nature effects your  genetic exactly if you like it that's  the interaction of nurture versus your  nature right it's the interaction  between the genetic information that you  have in instructions as it plays out  with the environment everything from the  music you heard and a baby when you were  a baby to the food to where your parents  live to the level of pollution etc etc